-Thank you very much, everyone!
Thank you!
Welcome, welcome,
welcome to "The Tonight Show"!
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, it is a big night
for the country
as Georgia held
its two runoff elections,
which will determine the balance
of power in the Senate.
It was exciting this morning
when MSNBC pried open the lid
and watched Steve Kornacki arise
from his hyperbaric chamber.
[ Laughter ]
"The Kornak is back
wearing the khak!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Because these races
are so important,
last night President Trump
traveled to Georgia and held
a rally on behalf of
the two Republican candidates,
Senator David Perdue
and Kelly Loeffler.
Yep, it was quite a night.
Trump spoke for
almost 90 minutes,
and then he invited everyone
on a scavenger hunt
to find 12,000 more votes.
[ Laughter ]
That was nice.
Yeah, the whole point of Trump's
visit was to rally support
for the two Republican
candidates,
but GOP officials were worried
he'd start talking about
his loss to Biden.
Let's see how long
he stayed on message.
-I want to thank you very much.
Hello, Georgia.
By the way, there's no way
we lost Georgia.
There's no way.
-Ah!
Five seconds. Well, way longer
than I expected.
Trump would read
"A Tale of Two Cities"
like, "It was the best of --
By the way, I am the best.
Everyone says I'm the best."
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, he's still
campaigning for an election
he already lost.
Imagine Justin Guarini
tweeting today,
"Text 50815 and make me
the next American Idol."
[ Laughter ]
It's been a while since Trump
made a campaign speech.
And he seemed a little rusty.
Listen closely to how he
pronounced the word America.
-We have made "Uhmeruca"
strong again.
Look at that arm.
-What happened?
W-W-What happened there?
It was like halfway through
a hypnotist put him to sleep.
[ Laughter ]
"We have made --"
Sleep!
"Uhmeruca strong again."
[ Laughter ]
"Is there ice in my shoe?"
[ Clucks ]
[ Laughter ]
It was either that
or one of his aides
hit him with a tranq dart.
"Uhmeruca."
Can we see it again there, Dave,
Uhmeruca?
-We have made Uhmeruca
strong again.
Look at that arm.
-"Look at that arm."
Distraction.
[ Laughter ]
If he can't say America,
why can't he just go
with the United States?
-God bless the United Shtates.
-Ah. That's why. That's why.
[ Laughter ]
Another big moment
during the speech was
when Trump brought up
Vice President Pence.
Yeah, Trump has been begging
Pence to stop Congress
from certifying the Electoral
College vote tomorrow.
Pence can't really do that,
but that hasn't stopped Trump
from pressuring him.
-I hope Mike Pence comes through
for us, I have to tell you.
He's a great guy.
Of course if he doesn't
come through,
I won't like him quite as much.
[ Laughter ]
-Pence's only role is to preside
over the ballot counting.
He's basically one step
above a bingo caller.
Wow.
[ Laughter ]
That's a respected profession
in this crowd.
[ Laughter ]
Bingo caller not that bad.
We like bingo caller.
He's the vice president.
Yeah. Mm.
Bingo caller.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, Trump said he hopes
Mike Pence
comes through tomorrow
and basically overturns
the election.
-Wait, wait, wait,
Trump wants Mike Pence
to swoop in
and overturn the results?
-Yeah, Mike Pence.
-Mr. Bore?
-Senior Snore.
-Dr. Doh?
-McDreary.
-Christian Pale?
-Ashen Kutcher.
-Android Cuomo?
-Robot de Niro.
[ Laughter ]
-Pence help?
-Hell no.
-Biden win?
-Once again.
-That's cool.
-That's right.
-Mm-hmm.
-Yep, yep.
-New Year's?
-Not bad.
-Gold plates?
-Stay at home?
-Champagne.
-Oh, yeah.
-Dom bomb?
-Cheap stuff.
-Headache?
-Real bad.
-Sorry, man.
-All good.
-Cool, cool.
Good talk.
-Best buds?
-Uh, do the monologue.
[ Laughter ]
-Right.
Meanwhile, during the trip
to Georgia, Ivanka Trump
tweeted a photo from Marine One
and accidently tagged the singer
Meat Loaf instead of her father.
[ Laughter ]
Secret Service was like,
"Ivanka, please, please,
don't give away his code name."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Ivanka tried to tag
@realdonaldtrump
but accidently ended up
with @realmeatloaf.
[ Laughter ]
In response Arby's was like,
"That's funny.
There's no such thing
as real meatloaf."
[ Laughter ]
Listen to this.
I read that the CEO of
Whole Foods, John Mackey,
is being criticized
after saying healthcare
would not be necessary
if people would eat better
and live healthier lifestyles.
Can't wait till
John breaks his leg
and the ER doctor prescribes him
a $20 mango.
[ Laughter ]
Some entertainment news --
last night was
the season premiere
of "The Bachelor."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
And the most talked about moment
was the arrival
of a woman who brought Matt
an interesting gift.
Watch this.
-I brought something
from home...
-Okay.
-...that's really special to me.
This pandemic was really hard
for me.
And this just really got me
through a lot.
And I was hoping to pass the
torch to you.
[ Laughter ]
-Who knew the naked dodgeball
season would end up
being the "classy" season?
[ Laughter ]
Then Chris Harrison was like,
"She's not a contestant.
I don't know how that lady
got in there.
Please wash your hands, please."
It'll be awkward in 10 years
when their kids are like,
"Mom, Dad, tell us about
when you first met."
[ Laughter ]
Just a reminder
that ABC is owned by Disney.
[ Laughter ]
People tune in like, "It'll be
nice to take a break
from all the horrible news
and just -- okay, you know what?
Back to CNN, let's put on CNN."
Eh.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a company that
makes face masks for pets
has seen a 500% increase in
sales since the pandemic began.
Here's a dog wearing
one of the masks.
Meanwhile, dogs
are going to be like,
"It's not COVID.
It's my breath, isn't it?"